es considerada como una de las mejores
vitrinas de cine del mundo los
preparativos para las 76ava edición de
la noche de apertura del festival de
cine de can están en marcha mientras la
alfombra roja es desplegada los
cazadores de famosos acuden en masa para
reservar un lugar en la Riviera es para
ver a las estrellas y para ver algunas
películas también para esta edición Se
esperan unos 35.000 asistentes
incluyendo un récord de siete directoras
nominadas en sus casi ocho décadas de
existencia mientras que 21 películas
compiten por el máximo galardón la palma
de oro el festival de este año está
encabezado por varios grandes estrenos
incluyendo Indiana Jones y el dial del
destino y la película de Martin scorsese
de la década de 1920 los asesinos de la
luna de las Flores sin embargo el evento
ya está envuelto en polémica la actriz
francesa Adela en él criticó al festival
luego de asegurar que sus organizadores
se hacen los de la vista ante los
depredadores sexuales refiriéndose al
regreso de Johnny Depp con la película
de apertura luego de las acusaciones de
abuso doméstico en su matrimonio con su
ex esposa Amber heard el director del
festival rechazó ambas críticas
sin duda por razones un tanto radicales
tuvo que hacer este comentario sobre can
Que obviamente es falso y estaba
equivocado
No me importa cuál sea la imagen de
Johnny Depp en Estados Unidos a decir
verdad solo es ver una película Solo
tengo una regla en la vida libertad de
pensamiento libertad de expresión
libertad de actuar dentro de la ley
el festival de cine de Khan Abre Este
martes 16 de mayo y durará hasta el
próximo día 27